the suicide squad is once again coming
to wreak unholy havoc on the world of
superhero movies
and if the first look footage james gunn
and company unleash during dc
fandom is any indication the director
may have outdone even himself with how
far he's willing to push the envelope of
insanity
for many die hard dc comics fans the
panel for james gunn's anti-superhero
team up licked the suicide squad was the
panel to watch during the online fandom
event
gunn didn't disappoint bringing
virtually the entire cast of the film
into the arena via an awesome zoom
session
the reveal cap hangs off with a look at
some behind the scenes footage complete
with cast interviews and a few finished
scenes from the movie
what should we expect from the film
we'll let gon answer that question
it's gonna be different from any
superhero movie ever made while gunn's
signature
sense of humor isn't fully on display on
the new promo video the director's
penchant for wild over-the-top action is
and it promises to be the sort of
unabashedly goofy bombast only gun can
deliver
it's easy to see why warner brothers and
dc entertainment executives were
so eager to snatch gun up after his
brief firing from marvel's guardians of
the galaxy vol
3. gunn's flare for outlandish action
was on full display in the first two
guardians of the galaxy movies
and if you have any familiarity with
suicide squad writer john ostrander's
comics you'll agree that gunn's twisted
sensibilities are particularly well
suited to bring the comics to life
the suicide squad promo reveals a few
returning anti-heroes from 2016's
much-maligned first attempt at the
suicide squad property as well as a
swath of new
characters from the dc comics canon it
finds gun dropping them all into a
literal war zone rife with big guns
super powered individuals and explosive
set pieces
everyone is exploding genitals heads
arms legs
in fact most of the footage in the promo
shows gunn and his effects crew
gleefully blowing stuff
up elsewhere there are several
intriguing looks at new members of the
suicide squad team
gun teases a wild cgi version of weasel
played by his brother sean gunn
michael rooker is sporting a crazy
blonde wig of savant
and john cena makes his first appearance
as peacemaker not everyone on the
suicide squad roster makes an appearance
in the promo footage but we know almost
all the facts about the cast
gun has assembled an absolutely mammoth
group of actors for the suicide squad
there are several actors reprising their
roles from david ayres original suicide
squad
margot robbie returns as harley quinn as
does joel kinnaman is rick flagg
viola davis is amanda waller and jai
courtney is captain boomerang
it doesn't stop there either we're also
getting daniela melchior as rat catcher
2
nathan phillian is tdk alicia braga as
solsoria plula borg as javelin and pete
davidson as blackguard
and still the cast goes on an
interesting side note about one of the
cast members
idris elbow was initially in talks to
play dead shot when will smith had to
drop out of the roll
we're very curious to see what elba's
take on bloodsport looks like as a
result
one thing you'll notice from the cast
reveal trailer is that there is one star
whose suicide squad role hasn't been
announced yet
taika ytt we can't wait to see what
character the what we do in the shadows
actor is going to play and what is sure
to be the most insane superhero movie
ever made
the suicide squad is set for release on
august 6 2021
so fans should get plenty more
information about the movie between now
and then
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc fan dome and the suicide squad
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one